you were talking about politicians
abdicating the role to growth to central
banks but I want to ask you about brexit
because last month you said if the
referendum vote were to happen then that
it was likely going to vote to leave do
you still hope that same view now no I
think President Obama when he visited
the UK changed the mood he yes a 78
percent approval rating in the UK and I
think he convinced many voters that it
would be the wrong thing to do for the
UK and I think all the issues around the
panamá investment patterns are have been
fully I think digested and I think those
issues are behind the Prime Minister and
so I actually see more momentum towards
a no vote why do you suppose though
there is this political rise of anger is
it that when you take a look at the
haves and have-nots many of the many of
those still that they have not
participated in the kind of growth that
we've seen in markets and the anger is
only growing I think you're right so
many families are working two jobs now
so many families have left jobs that had
more security two jobs with less
security so many families have left jobs
in manufacturing to the service side at
smaller wages and in many cases so many
families have a secure job but they have
not witnessed any increases in their
compensation or the compensation hasn't
kept up with inflation so you put that
all together and yet you're seeing such
a disparity of wealth as you suggested
the one thing that is very certain
what quantitative easing is done
worldwide and low interest rates it
helped people who have capital equity
markets rallied the average participant
in society doesn't have enough savings
to be in the equity markets or onal
large pools of real estate so you've
seen this widening
yeah those who have capital have
benefited those who had a lot of debt
and been able to refinance benefited but
the typical middle-class have not
benefited and this is the anger the
middle-class throughout the world kids
in the dog world have been crunched and
that's what Donald Trump is tapping into
national versus globalism what does a
president Trump mean for a global
economy and what does he mean for what
natural market well I think whoever's
president whoever is there be the
leaders of the UK and Spain whoever the
leaders in countries that are not having
an election I think it's a wake-up call
that we have this anger that we have
families who've lost hope that they're
worried about their children and their
children's future this is why I think
it's essential we need this fiscal
policy response why this fiscal policy
response needs to be in the directed
towards infrastructure that we can
create better higher-quality jobs higher
paying jobs in building necessary
infrastructure for a better future for a
better future for their children and
their grandchildren and I think it's
very essential so whoever its president
and if it whether it is Donald Trump or
not Donald Trump whether its Prime
Minister Cameron or Boris Johnson it
means you have to respond to these
issues